let K equals four so that f of X is
equal to one over x squared minus four X
determine whether F has a relative
minimum a relative maximum or neither at
x equals two justify your answer all
right well if f of X is equal to this
then F prime of X they gave us F prime
of X in terms of K so f prime of X is
going to be equal to in this case K is 4
so it's going to be 4 minus 2 x 4 minus
2 x over x squared minus 4 x squared
minus 4x minus 4 x squared so now we
know f of X and we know F prime of X and
if we were looking for relative minima
or relative maxima we would be
interested in in points and the critical
points and especially where F prime of X
is equal to 0 and so if we said f prime
of X is equal to 0 well we could say
well when does this numerator equal a 0
and so you could say when does 4 minus
2x equal 0 you had 2x to both sides you
get 4 is equal to 2 X or X is equal to 2
X is equal to 2 and they told us that or
I guess we've confirmed that at at F
prime F prime of 2 does indeed equal to
0 so this is definitely an interesting
point so let's think about whether
before when X is less than 2 is f prime
of X increasing or decreasing and then
when X is greater than 2 is f prime of X
increasing or decreasing and that
that'll let us know if this is a minima
or a Maxima so let's say so when when x
is less than 2 we could test something
out we could say F prime of so let's
just say F prime of 1 so if X is less
than 2 and you actually don't even have
to test F prime of 1 I mean you could if
you want you would have 4 minus 2 4
minus 2 times 1 so that's going to be
positive and then this down over here is
always going to be
negative because you have a squared
right over here so when X is less than 2
f prime of X is greater than 0 and you
could try this out with different X's if
you like you could say for example for
example f prime of 1 is equal to 4 minus
2 which is 2 over 1 minus 4 which is
negative 3 but then squared is equal to
2 ninths and then we could say when when
X is greater than 2 f prime of X F prime
of X well when X is greater than 2 you
have 4 minus 2 times something larger
than 4 so this is going to be negative
so f prime of X is going to be less than
0 appear is going to be negative down
here is not going to be negative and so
f prime of X is going to be less than 0
so if if we are increasing as we
approach something and then our slope is
0 and then we are decreasing well then
this is going to be a maximum point so
that means that we have a maximum
maximum point point at X is equal at X
is equal to or we could say yes we have
F has a relative maximum relative
maximum at x equals at x equals 2 and
actually listen to me right X has a
relative maximum I'm just use the words
they are using relative relative maximum
at X is equal to 2 now another way that
you could have tried to do it is you
could have try to take the second
derivative of this and then solve
whether that was positive or negative
and whether it's concave upwards or
downwards but taking the second
derivative this it gets quite hairy and
anytime you're taking the AP test and
you find yourself going down a really
really hairy path like taking the
derivative of well taking the second
derivative derivative of F which would
be the first derivative
f-prime anytime you see yourself going
down a hairy path like that it might
work but it's probably not the optimal
path so not an easier way to just think
okay well what is f prime doing as we
approach this or another way is thinking
is the function increasing as we
approach from below and is it is it
increasing or decreasing as we get
beyond that point beyond x equals two